I brush my teeth I smile but there is
always this
frown I think I'll run away with the
ants and live on
Mars I'm fortunate because I'm a poet
and Poets are allowed to be hopeful I
used to dream radical dreams of blowing
everyone away with my perceptive powers
of care direct analysis I don't remember
a lot of
[Music]
things but a lot of things that I don't
remember I don't choose to remember
childhood remembrances are always a drag
if you're
black I remember what's important and I
make up the
rest that's what storytelling is all
about I even used to think I'd be the
one to stop the riot and negotiate the
peace would you ever say that some of
your poems were inspired by stress or
hate were you ever bullied by your skin
color when you were younger have you
ever had like a breakdown or you
couldn't take anym where you just
couldn't do
it but there has to be a way to do what
we do and survive our ancestors taught
us how to do
that the one thing that I did know is
whatever life would be I knew I had to
create myself to successfully go to Mars
and back you will need a
song and maybe a six-pack so if there is
life on Mars you can
share popcorn for the celebration when
you land while you wait on your land LS
to kick
in and as you climb down the ladder from
your spaceship to the Martian surface
look to your left and there you'll see a
smiling Community quilting a blackeyed
pee watching you descend
[Music]
h